hello this year's annual meetings Kim is
waiting redesign rebuild and I think
with considering this a very nice James
I would like to raise the question of
state sovereignty I think it is a good
time to redefine the concept of state
sovereignty in a way that oppressive
government would not be able to appraise
you know they've people to violate their
people the government such as Iran
government and especially since
fraudulent election and cracking down
protest and trying to you know to rise
people to a stopped coming today sleet
and to protest again is at the state so
this is responsibility of international
community to take em you know
responsibility to raise and criticize
Iran's government regarding human rights
violation there are other you know few
countries that are pressing their people
so I think it is time to raise and to
redefine the concept of a state
sovereignty I hope at the final report
of the annual meeting we could see
reflection of this new definition on the
final report thank you